Fernando is with us in Texas hi Fernando
how are you hello Dave what an honor
thank you for taking my call
sure my pleasure how can I help yes sir
so I just got done with baby step three
thank God and so now I'm gonna start
putting money in my 401k and there's a
few everyday millionaires at my job and
they all tell me to invest in the
traditional because of a tax break but I
listen to you hardcore and I know it's
raw so my question is can you please
reassure me that Roth is the right
decision for me so how much how old are
you I'm thirty-three sir
okay and how much will you be putting
into your 401 K so the 5% to get to
match and so at least five but the maxed
it out it would be like twenty four
percent sir that's around 750 a month if
I max it out okay well you wouldn't max
it out unless you have your house paid
for yes sir I have not okay we tell you
to put fifteen percent of your income
maximum into retirement so let's just
use an example let's say you put five
hundred dollars a month in okay yeah we
use that as our example gonna start with
nothing in there your thirty three and
we'll do this until age 63 which would
be thirty years right okay follow me
okay yes so if you put five hundred
dollars a month away for 30 years in a
decent growth stock mutual fund I have
to put this in here again because I
didn't do it right somehow
all right let's try that there we go
you'd have about a million seven hundred
thousand dollars okay okay all right
and keep in mind that during that time
you put in six thousand dollars thirty
times you've put in 180 thousand but
there's a million seven in there so
we'll say you put in two hundred
thousand and there's a million five in
growth right yeah okay
in a traditional you have paid taxes on
none of the money so you'll pay taxes on
the entire seven 1.7 million dollars
taxes on that would probably be four
hundred thousand bucks
okay okay in a in a Roth you will have
already paid your taxes on the 200 that
you put in because it's an after-tax
investment and the growth the other 1.5
million is 100% tax-free so when you get
to retirement you're either going to pay
taxes on 1.7 million or you're going to
have 1.7 million tax-free the difference
in this discussion is probably somewhere
around $400,000 oh wow
kind of makes sense doesn't it yes
that's why I say that so doesn't really
matter what I say
what matters is why I say it absolutely
and so you've what you got to do is just
figure out okay this is why and so now
you can make your own decision do you
want 1.7 or do you want 1.3 after taxes
and you know you can just side which one
you want it but obviously you're gonna
be the pick the big number it's really
not hard you know so there's a lot of
mathematical discussions around
everything with the Roth that people
that don't think about the actual facts
are that people end up putting the same
amount into a Roth that they would put
into the other even though it doesn't
take the same amount of money to get
there actually takes more money to get
the same amount into a Roth because you
it's an after-tax going in and so people
run these hypothetical mathematical
discussions trying to run an
apples-to-apples and in reality the way
people actually use the tool it's not an
apples to apples comparison the way they
use it is he's gonna put in 500 bucks
whether it's rather whether it's not so
he's going to put in so it's not an out
it's not really apples to apples in that
sense but still just the same the Roth
is the way to go always do Roth always
do Roth unless you're 60 years old or
older and then you can consider maybe
going the other direction but and the
reason is the illustration I just gave
you it's a four hundred thousand dollar
discussion in your example